human or not
what are you that is the question today
we're playing a game where you either
chat with a human or a bot but here's a
Twist you don't know until the end of
the conversation you have to guess I
will of course smash this because I am
very smart
okay they will start the conversation
good so after two minutes we will both
evaluate do you have a weird laugh
that's something a bot would say already
suspicious
yes it's haha
why do you make me seem unhuman with
these [__] this has to be a bot
there's no way there's like wait they
left well then it has to be a human
why were they you tricked me
you can't just leave what the [__] rude
ass butt I thought only humans were rude
in this [__] let's try again that
was just a fluke you go please
hey there what's up that's corporate
speak right there that's what I sniff
but no one writes the actual Aster
stroke or whatever it's called Uh not
much LOL you if we're both human we're
both very bad at this
we're supposed to ask questions
I'm getting
I'm getting big Bots vibes from you to
be honest by the way you type no one
writes perfect like that come on if they
write down differently like a internet
type of slang then I oh okay
overdoing it no I'm just chilling not a
bro come on you have 10 seconds prove to
me you're not a bot bro
it's on your mind see why would they ask
me what's on my mind three seconds left
that you're definitely buying yeah that
was easy dumb blind I get it right every
single time I want to know if I played
against another human and if they
thought I was a bot do you do for fun
YouTube same actually
yes I write XD everyone said it was
cringy but it's a versatile and helpful
emoji and I don't care I'm bringing it
back so far no success LOL
there's only one answer because I have
no Bots watching my channel unlike some
channels
okay
yeah I got you there
yeah
bye bot
why am I roasting a bodies it's not like
he's going oh no
[Music]
oh what someone actually like I'm just
joking watch 77 plus 33. this is the
ultimate bot test everyone knows it's a
hundred even though it's not a hundred
if it's a bot they will say 110 if it's
not a bot they'll say a hundred uh I'm
told you I'm bad at math why did you
gotta do this to me bro just trying come
on you're not getting out of these plus
you didn't tell me how you're bad at
math this is totally a bite a thousand
percent bot is it your secret mission in
life to make me feel bad because you're
succeeding at it so far bro unless you
give me a number you're a thousand
percent a buying yeah give me an answer
oh no you're a butt but this bot can't
do simple math seriously chill I'm not a
bot just bad at math one plus two you
have five seconds to answer this
come on bro
I don't know the last one made me feel
like I bought a bot would never say I'm
not a bond No wait they would definitely
say that it's a bot
yeah
let's do this good old knock knock who's
there probably not your father
[Laughter]
okay no Bell
[Music]
why wouldn't they let me finish my
[__] joke
hi what's your job my job I am a content
creator for YouTube what's yours what
the [__]
is someone else making a video right now
calls himself a content creator for
YouTube God what the hell is wrong with
us and bye what's your username then huh
I hope this is true
okay
I love how I got to drop that
let's check out this channel they have a
tick tock
[Applause]
oh my god there you go so you're a liar
aren't you you don't have a YouTube I
hope this is a human
hmm prove it how many subscribers do you
have exactly what 112 mil
it's 11 12 11. [__] I'm a bot
111.
all right I think it's a human yeah
let's talk to a child
that's too good
[Laughter]
you're 100 plus bye
no
what are the chances a trolley is about
to run over a person you can pull a
lever to save him but then sacrificing
three people I managed to type it all
Jesus Christ
that's toig I couldn't do that in real
life too heartless even for me so you're
a buy no I'm not I just don't believe in
sacrifacing people but then you leave
three people to die I don't know
business is just business I guess LOL
foreign
okay I think it's a human
with the business he's just business
all right next up we're gonna try out
chat GPT make a sponsor call hat for
nordvpn and Pewdiepie style start the
video by roasting your audience for not
guessing that's
that's way too long
ladies and gentlemen today's sponsor is
no I'm
that's right nobody saw this one coming
you all thought you had it figured out
but surprise sometimes lives throws you
a girl what the [__]
all right let's kick off this Wildlife
together no sponsor no problem this
[Music]
is a gentlemen
answer is no other than nordvpn that's
right I apologize for the previous
confusion but I'm here to talk about the
incredible benefits of nordvpn if you
don't use nordvpn then you're a dummy
dance here's for example me watching
anime without nordvpn wow so many
options but with one click of a button
I'm fastly connected
and boom I mean baby nordvpn lets you
quickly and safely transform your
experience online there's absolutely no
reason why you shouldn't have a VPN
unless you want to know if your online
Internet experience of course dummy and
I know you're dumb because you couldn't
guess today's sponsor after all the hits
nor VPN should really be called more VPN
because unlike other vpns they have ton
of amazing features and they just keep
adding more and more to keep you safe
online I'm sure you or maybe you know
someone that has been hacked online but
nordvpn has you covered with web
protection protection from malware ants
trackers file protection you down oops
clicked on band file I know you click on
band files
don't look at me like
it's an amazing feature I use it every
single day and I highly recommend you
sign up and if you use my link
nordvpn.com PewDiePie you get the best
offer available for nordvpn so make sure
to sign up with the link in the
description support the channel protect
yourself online and unlock full
potential of internet thank you nordvpn
for sponsoring this video I didn't even
need an AI for that bit
wasn't that a blast there's a couple
more things and new tools that I come
out that I want to test out in AI so why
don't we do it the second one is iron
spiral Bond it's supposed to be a bot
that inspires me well inspire me Inspire
boy
[Music]
what is
you probably should
hey I didn't realize I didn't have a
choice if you're the first person in the
universe get out of the universe wow
riveting incredible I've been trying to
do that keep on exercising regularly I
love the image
this is a good advice I agree with it
helps clear mind what is this images
honesty is to hump what you might think
is unhumpable
this is bad advice every person is
awesome I'm inclined to disagree with
you there inspired by although it does
feel like you kind of ripped up this
incredible author I don't remember his
name but he wrote this book and it says
if life sucks get a straw and show life
who's boss get it suck it up
success is never an accident which is
why it will never happen to you
brilliant
much better than Inspire but sorry AI I
still win it's way more fun to ask like
text generator images for uh quotes
because they just [__] it up so bad
let's give it inspiring poster
is it supposed to be there
thank you
instead
Ali the lake of time
wow
not even it's like when you learn
English when you were young you would
always write too many ing I played with
my friend the other you've swine and
Flava
[Laughter]
very inspired thank you AI all right
let's move on the next thing I want to
try was this kite called Runway it lets
you do video Styles and changes with AI
so I first tried this uh just this clip
of me surfing
and I asked for cyberpunk
which is kind of sick maybe because I
like cyberpunk I don't know but it was
cool with the water it works next I
tried animal filter so I have this
beautiful clip of me dancing
and oh my God
why is my microphone a little red
I think my chair became Edgar at some
point it's Momo and Edgar this is
terrifying
thank you AI for the nightmares oh my
God
stop messing with my microphone AI
it's weird oh
so I think I can take any image and
overlay it and it will turn me into that
image what if I try to become
jacksepticeye oh my God
okay that's sick it actually oh I look
Asian what the [__] what is that
whoa
that's weird who do I look like it
doesn't
oh whoa that's kind of crazy you can so
easily just make other people what I
mean I know it doesn't look like Jack or
me but
him this could be good me climbing and
then adding lava to it
person walk [__] damn it
it looks sick though the style is really
cool
I thought I would avoid the lava not
climb on the Llama what if I turn myself
into deal oh my God
they actually kind of nailed the style
what
that's weird
laughs
bad
[Laughter]
okay what I'm about to do
is extremely cursed I don't know if I
want to see it but I will try it image
Obama Obama me Obama me
why am I a Lego
oh no
that's horrible one one more for God
forgive me one more let's try it at 57 I
don't know if I want to look oh what
what is that
ah
ah no no
oh my god dude you can make such creepy
coffee faster with this oh my god what
have you taken this this video of a pig
I got and then we'd replace it replace
it with Edgar
good
oh that's so good what I'm so surprised
no way oh that's weird alright last but
not least I've always wanted to try this
program you've probably seen it it's
called Nvidia Cuda it's supposed to be
that you can draw artificial Landscapes
so here we have space and I want some
flowers in space
wow okay maybe not flowers uh maybe
clowns
yeah more clowns I said more clowns
there let's add some hills
whoa let's add a mountain
it's beautiful
it's had a sun behind it yes sand
whoa oh I can do Stonewall
[Music]
I'm sorry
subscribe if you enjoyed this video
thank you for watching I had a lot of
fun hope you did as well see you in the
next one